Go ahead and play the lottery, whatever. But just
let's remember what it is. It's a tax on the poor.
When you buy a lottery ticket, all of that money
goes into a big pot. And in my mind it's like, oh,
it goes into this big pot, and then whoever
wins it gets all that money. That's not how
it works. Only like 40% of it goes to the
actual, like, winner of the jackpot. A lot
of the other money goes to the stores that
sell the lottery tickets. The company that,
like, helps advertise and run the lottery. And of
course, a giant chunk goes to Uncle Sam. I mean,
that's why lotteries exist. That's why
governments run the lottery is because
they need to raise extra money. People don't
like taxes, so the lottery just makes taxes fun.
That money usually goes into public programs like
parks and education. Or in the case of Nebraska,
it goes into like funding their state fair. OK.
The fact is the lottery is a tax and it is a
tax that's borne particularly by people who have
less education, who live in poorer neighborhoods,
and whose money goes into the big lottery
jackpot and doesn't actually come back to benefit
their neighborhood. It's not like a tax that
actually benefits them in any material way. So.